welcome welcome welcome he's
back wo with society's least asked for
stories homeschooled HOA Consultants
budlight Ronda santis business Fred
Flintstone I'm going to be talking about
Chuck-E-Cheese for and I'm not kidding
about this the next 25 minutes you can
stop watching this at any time if you
like but this studio audience cannot
leave covering up to the minute breaking
news knock knock who's there not the
Hindenberg that's for sure 36 dead in
New Jersey and Diving medium deep into
history we don't have time to talk about
the history of the Middle East tonight
and I know you're thinking but John are
you sure about that aren't you school
well fun fact I'm not it just seems like
that I'm actually technically a comedy
show I just hide it better than most
with a host who's not afraid to tell you
the hard facts most of the dogs you knew
are dead in the US the retirement age is
no the first song Charlie poth ever
masturbated to was this love by Maroon
Five that's a true fact and I hate that
I know it but I love that you now know
it too and to say the words that others
are afraid to oats oats give me oats y
nom nom nom nom nom and this is true a
chuga chuga choo chuo and ding ding ding
ding ding and always treating serious
topics with the gravity they deserve
just watch me bounce bounce bounce
bounce this is what democracy is all
about America interfering in foreign
elections last Week Tonight with John
[Music]
Oliver